uh to reach the people that are that are
there for the northwest of course the
the situation is much more is much more
complex uh of course uh you know the
there are many many uh casualties
between uh a number of people injured
uh what we have been unable since the
earthquake started this is the beginning
of the earthquake of course the road
leading from gaziantep uh to the border
to the transshipment point uh was was
damaged of course and that and that road
was was closed so we couldn't uh send
any relief items and we were looking for
alternative routes and luckily today
we're hearing that the road is is
opening we do have a possibility
hopefully uh to to access to access the
Border uh we're working with the with
our with our Turkish counterparts to uh
to also uh give us all the support but I
think we have a glimpse of Hope there
that the road is accessible and we can
reach we can reach the people the UN
agencies the ngos the Syrian ngos are
are of course uh ready uh to uh to
deploy humanitarian Aid and and as I
said we're we are hoping that that
tomorrow we will be able to deliver to
deliver something and cross across the
border of course in addition to that
in addition to the cross-border we are
trying to complement that with the with
the coastline Mission and I will leave
that to my colleague and Mustafa uh to
to to talk more about it but as but as
we always say we see ourselves uh you
know our our objective is to reach the
people for us across border and
crossline are just modalities
complementing each other the most
important thing that we reach people in
this desperate in this in this time
people who are desperate for uh for help
in this in this very difficult situation
we're seeing images on TV children
stranded in very harsh cold winter
snowing uh it's it's really it's really
hard heartbreaking I'm gonna stop here
and pass it to my colleague al-mustafa
of course to speak about the other part
of the humanitarian work he is leading
and then I'm happy also to complement
and to answer any questions I'll Mustafa
over to you thank you very much I thank
you very much let me just as
first let me
convey my or present my condolences and
sympathies to all the people who lost a
life
a relative whether or into care or in in
Syria
this is a tragedy this is a big
a big catastrophe if you want
just the total number of the people
affected now is 10.9 million and I'm
talking about all the borders within
Syria all all the people of Syria 10.9
million affected by this uh
by this terrible earthquake but before
the terrible earthquake we have as
mentioned by uh Hadi uh we had 12 years
of Crisis and a huge limitation crisis
we had 15.3 million people in need
we have uh six million
uh or four million needing needing humid
targeting assistance basic humanitarian
assistance so it's a crisis on top of a
crisis
uh how deep is the crisis I think we
have seen the the images and the videos
and the YouTube from
from Japan but we have seen them also
from from Syria in halab and
also from uh the all the the five
governorates that are affected here in
Syria there are actually five Governor
Governors affected the governorates of
Hama that of ladakia
and discovers it discovers I read
discovers the whole the whole of uh that
region and that's around
uh 10 million people and the 10 million
actually goes even Beyond which when you
look at the situation and what's
happened we have people also affected in
the result and in America
uh their their houses their units have
suffered also and many of them are not
ready to stay there many are not ready
to go back to their to their houses and
this is happening also in hadap
happening and I've been in italypt
in all those places just to give you an
example sorry
we have 30 000 people who are now living
in shelters these are schools and
mosques and uh and those are the lucky
ones
but we know from a very quick and dirty
assessment in halam done with whatever
means we have that's one third of the
houses or the buildings have been
affected uh if you count that and it's
that's equivalent to some twenty
thousand houses make just five
persons per family that's hundred
thousands that means that we have
seventy thousand who are not as lucky as
the thirty thousand sitting in in
shelters who are struggling with the
cold and just this morning even here in
Damascus we had snow
there they have snow they have freezing
cold weather and they're living in
terrible situation I think that is
applied also to the Northwest it's
applied to a queen and even maybe worse
but what we have here we have a
situation where we have already a very
vulnerable situation people already
vulnerable not capable of taking care of
themselves or just trying to get out of
it
and all of a sudden comes this
and all the achievements we had before
anybody who had that small business now
has lost that small business anybody who
could go to school cannot go to school
women who could go to protection centers
cannot go to protection centers so it's
a terrible situation where even the 15.3
million people that were in need here in
Syria now we have to revise that number
and maybe this time uh the the this This
Disaster will help us do things
better uh uh just mentioned those
figures but think also of the roads
infrastructure uh already the area
suffered from very poor infrastructure
because of the crisis full roads water
electricity fuel name it and now we have
this situation and we are struggling
with it it does affect our human Target
in working
uh I I'm aware of reservoirs of water
who either collapse or are in the risk
of collapsing the those tanks of water
that are elevated many if not the
majority need to repair or replacement
so just this is the suffering of the
people
and I think we need to do something
about it
what we are doing if you want
the U.N and its Partners actually
started working from the first hour of
the disaster from the first hour of this
because we used we had our own stocks of
food non-food items hygiene kits dignity
kids some medical
they were available uh there at at the
border with the at the Samaritan sorry
and some were already pre-positioned not
that we expected this disaster to happen
but there were prepositioned there and
we have been using these
stocks now to address the needs and
these stocks are being depleted that
means if we are using these stocks and
we are also diverting stocks from other
areas in the country to the area
affected now that means that the people
who need it and still need that are now
being deprived of that so I'm saying
this to say that we didn't stay waiting
we started working and I hope as Hadi
Mohammad just mentioned that we uh what
we are here for we are talking about
humanitarian need we are talking now
people who need that that support now
and whatever we can do
we have to do it together driven by the
human target needs and we just hope that
the political considerations and so on
will get out of the way and let us do
our work
very much you now open the floor for
questions please go ahead
thank you for your briefing because I'll
base you with independent uh my question
is for you about uh
we've been hearing reports that
countries like Greece and Israel that
traditionally aren't politically close
with turkey are actually sending Aid I
wanted to ask you in practicality on the
ground do you actually see this help and
aid from other countries like Greece and
Israel thank you
foreign
yourself I can't hear you I can't hear
you
oh yeah it's good now thank you
okay yeah
okay uh you want me to take it or you
take it but anyway uh I started will add
yes I have received a calls uh not I'm
aware of the offer by Greece I'm uh I I
received calls from other areas
including Jordan including some private
sites in Thailand and I'm sure there are
other people who are there to to help
and want to help what I can tell you is
that the government said when we met the
Minister of Foreign Affairs the first
day he said that we are open to all
assistance to all help and we will
facilitate not only the incoming of the
help whether it's physical or money or
uh
and so on and they would then facilitate
that
that's all I can I can say uh there is a
there is a mechanism whoever approaches
us we are trying to help in uh
coordinating that
I don't know whether it answers the
question but I I have the feeling I
missed something I uh
River
I'll cry we say Hadid you want to add
no um please I'm fine to add if you like
basically
um
our humanitarian work is
not political we are governed by the
humanitarian principles and we are
people focused we are not politics
focused and I want to remind here
everybody including myself that
basically the the first responsibility
of the welfare and well-being of the
people are the host government and we as
the United Nations and the International
Community are helping people by request
of the government
so it's for the government to take those
those political decisions for us we
totally depoliticize our work and
Mustafa and myself our our main focus
and every colleague including our
colleagues and the NGO International and
local ngos will focus on the people uh
on the on the needs of the women and the
children and we leave the politics uh
totally aside so uh we're happy to to to
work where wherever the Aid comes from
because we do not politicize it provided
that the host governments uh are you
know they they understand it and they
you know they do their own their own
Arrangement around it uh so thank you
thank you I mean Michelle please uh
thank you thanks so much for the
briefing Michelle Nichols from Reuters a
couple of practical practical questions
um first of all on Northwest Syria you
spoke about the road from gazian Tech to
the transit trans shipment Hub what
about the road from The transshipment
Hub into Syria is it possible is it
usable if you get the aid to the
transshipment hub can you then just
restart the operation as normal
um our I know the UN won't be doing this
but are you are aware of any other Aid
groups using the barbell Salam border
crossing which the UN used to use before
it was shut down is anyone using that is
the UN coordinating with the white
helmets in Northwest Syria who seem to
be leading some of the rescue search and
rescue efforts there and then just with
regard to the crossline deliveries
um
is there any way of scaling can that be
scaled up to meet the needs
effectively in Northwest Syria what have
been some of the traditional challenges
that you've faced with those crossline
deliveries
um if you could just give us a reminder
of that and are you hoping to that to
overcome those challenges now during
this emergency situation thanks
most of I'm happy to start and then I'll
pass it to you if you don't mind to
compliment
thanks on your on your first question
about the uh about the road of course
there are as you said there are two
segments there are two legs to that uh
as I said earlier the first part which
is uh to the on the Turkish side we're
hoping that this is now is is usable the
second part the information we're
getting that it is it's also probably we
can we can use it mind you information
is is hard to verify and we're working
with all of our partners to make sure
that the information we get is as
accurate but what I want to to tell you
for for for sure is that our trucks are
are ready we already have trucks at at
the border we have trucks being
being loaded so we are the willingness
is there we're just waiting for the
ability of of the logistics and the
access to uh to do it we're working
through our partners we're trying to
verify if I'm as much information as we
can we have the logistics cluster which
is uh with all the expertise that they
have uh trying to verify to make sure
that the operation is as smooth as as
possible uh we're using Babel Hawa we're
not using I think other others are using
it uh on the issue of coordination we're
coordinating as as much as we can
coordination usually is very important
at this critical time coordination
becomes much more important yet much
more much more complex of course but
also we're doing ourselves we're doing
our best to make sure that Orchard leads
the coordination among all the
international communities we have the UN
agencies we have international ngos we
have local Syrian ngos who are doing
outstanding outstanding work and of
course we have the right helmet and much
much and many more people helping so
we're doing our best to make sure that
all that everybody that the efforts are
well coordinated it's difficult it's
challenging yet it's something that we
are focused on and we're trying our best
on the cross line and and the
cross-border of course uh both uh my
colleague al-mustafa and myself we see
crossline and cross-border as as two
modalities complement each other we
would like to to to bring in the issue
of efficiency and Effectiveness here the
idea is to reach people in the fastest
cheapest uh best way we can uh crossline
as of today does not does not replace
cross-boulder we are hoping that
everybody puts the interest of the
people first we keep the politics aside
we move that the authorities all
authorities move away from the issue
from from the politics and put the
interest of the people first we would
like to see the cross line escalated uh
as much as as possible also the cross
line we have to do more crossline but
again we have to we would like to see
them working together to reach the
people at the time of need I'll pass it
back to my colleague Mustafa
uh can you please meet yourself Mr uh
Pelham Lee
are you still muted I'm sorry we can't
hear you
oh can you hear me yes thank you can you
help me yeah
um
and there's no it's not about crossline
and cross-border it's about the lives in
that area and what can we do I know that
now they're struggling and I know that
the level of Destruction is quite High
very quite High very high I know that
the people do not have what it needs for
the rescue and the search and rescue I
know that the conditions of traveling
are difficult and I know also and we all
know that there
suffering from the snow and the freezing
temperature so for me for us for
Muhammad is how do we get there
and let me just say one thing uh we
already had within that area we had
prepositioned
supplies food wfp nude FPA others had
supplies and food there a new HCR and we
started using these slides and Foods
through the mechanisms and through the
networks that we have there and in
addition to this we are ready from here
from to increase our uh it's not about
presence it's about reaching the people
who need our help so that's one thing
but
from this side we are working with the
with the all the governorates to try to
find different entry points into the
northwest
in addition to samarda and we are
working on it because soon those
supplies that we have there will deplete
will be depleted and we are bringing who
is bringing two planes from their
warehouse in Dubai with medical supplies
and medical equipment and emergency
medical supplies
[Music]
they will need to get there and I just
hope that once
for once everybody keeps first the
interest of the people and we have seen
them dying under the rubble and some of
them are still asking for help
I'm asking for all our partners all of
them to facilitate and put whatever
question because this is for the people
we are ready with the with the supplies
we still have supplies to take us few
few days here to take to all these areas
and we are working on this replenishing
and we still need more support
I just want to say something the figures
that are mentioned and have been
mentioned are much much less than the
reality that we might end up with this
is not something uh simple I heard
people talking about five seven times
the figures we are talking about
I hope that the undoc mission that is
here now will help us get to some
serious assessments of the situation it
will take some time and we have to
address all those while while we are
struggling with many other complications
and I hope we can get the help of
everybody to address this thank you just
one quick follow-up I know it's not a
new issue but can you just remind us of
what the challenges have been to scaling
up the crossline deliveries why haven't
you been able to scale up crossline to
meet the needs
um in a way that the cross-border
operation meets those needs
okay uh let me just answer this one in
the last seven in the last seven to
eight months
in the last seven to eight months we
have been able to reach through cross
lines with nine convoys and we have been
saying that we can do more we can do
three four five crossline more because
it's just the need has to be addressed
we can increase the size of the uh the
convoys from 14 15 tracks to much higher
we are ready and we are waiting for all
our partners all the people to
facilitate that
thank you so the government is the
problem
I did not say that
the government is the
government now is not the problem either
the government is saying you will have
all the facilitation
all the the letters we call something
facilitation letters that they provide
for us to move and they delivered on
this they promised the first day two
hours later we got all of these to get
to la de Kia to get to the coastal area
and carry some quick and dirty
assessments of the situation and the
government is saying please go ahead
thank you please
hi this issue with China central
television a couple questions first
um you just mentioned that those those
uh supports would last only a few days
so what are the things that mostly
needed in need and do you have what what
is what thing is the most in shortage
for you to help this uh relief
and and second when you said that now
the Syrian government is not a problem
and they they will they will they
promise to facilitate you to go to uh to
to help the humanitarian efforts
um do you have plans now so far to have
cross-line uh humanitarian assistance in
the in the short shortcoming future and
and more uh yesterday the Syrian
permanent representative here said that
some of the cargo ship even they want to
help Syria cannot land in Syrian airport
would that be a problem if if we see the
whole operation the relief operation
that this might be a problem for the you
know the the Assistance or resources to
allocate to to Syria and to help people
thank you
should I take it or yeah
you would like to start I'll check it
then I'll give it back to you Mohammed
if you want please yes thank you yeah go
ahead go ahead go right please go ahead
I'll compliment
can you hear me yes
uh I'll start with the needs the needs
are let's say this is happening in in a
tropical area
you would need food you would need a
shelter you would need water you would
need generators because they're in the
places where you might not have
generators you would need a medical you
would need trauma kids you would need uh
support to and you need protection these
are the ones
but to this the fact that we are working
in an environment that is already a
vulnerable and suffering environment
where there is no fuel
the the infrastructure is suffering and
suffered the houses where they're living
are suffering and there might be other
collapses in this case for example we
will need again the rubble moving we
will need the search and rescue and we
will need uh
uh we are in a cold place winter clothes
sheets
uh
uh everything that you need when you are
in a very difficult situation this is
what we need
and maybe there is some more Medical
and we need to the facilitation of this
work we need to get there this is an
area again where you already have a
conflict and various parties we are
working here and trying to coordinate at
the level between Muhammad myself and
Paul we are also communicating
regularly with headquarters and the
various agencies
just to give you an example today and
this is a good question again today we
have Tadros from who
Martin will be here in two days ICA rcrc
was was here uh just recently uh some
more are coming I'm forgetting and you
know what
people are
getting into it's not Aid fatigue now
it's assessment fatigue we need action
we are doing it will take us only a few
days I'll answer the question about how
much it will go I'll give you an example
wfp has enough to feed hundred thousand
people for one week
so to answer the question we have one
week
okay now the next question is
whether those planes would land I just
can't repeat what the government said is
the facilitation
and promised in in some meetings but
that's a question that should go again
to uh to the to the government and I
don't have full answer to it
yes thank you uh I just want to you know
to really State the obvious uh that
everybody knows about you know having
the crossline missions is something very
complex even before the even before the
earthquake it needed multiple levels of
coordination between different parties
security
humanitarian ngos so it's not a
straightforward it's not a
straightforward operation add to that
it's a military active Zone where we had
to operate in a military zone so it's
not easy we try our best we as
al-mustafa said yes the U.N has the the
willingness and the ability to do this
but it's not just about the United
Nations it's about the other parties
that we have to to coordinate with and
we don't spare any efforts to increase
the number of of cross of crossline
missions but it's easier said than done
however we're still hopeful with this
situation that we can do more on
crossline and more on cross-border thank
you
uh thank you I'm Gregory supporting Cafe
task news agency uh please uh questions
for both speakers and so uh what are the
initial plans so for un uh on the terms
of how to proceed
urgent life-saving assistance
especially given the situation of
sanctions which were imposed against
Syria and please the second one uh
please can you uh could you please uh
confirm the exact numbers of
anti-halera dose of vaccines which were
provided to the to the territories which
control under the government thank you
I think we lost New York no I'm coming
back it's just I'm not in control of
that one oh no uh
uh the uh there are three questions
life-saving assistance
sanctions and cholera
the first one on life-saving assistance
you know uh uh the U.N can only offer
what it can get so it depends on what
you can bring to us and how you can help
those are things that we have to ask and
we are trying to get to your attention
the needs and definitely the heavy
equipment for search and rescue is
needed it will also be needed after 72
hours when we stop the search and rescue
for the rubble moving and clearance uh
you know that here it's a situation
where fuel is missing and we need to do
something immediately about it before we
get to the sanctions and all the stuff
we do not have enough uh
uh pieces for of equipment to replace or
to to repair some of the equipment like
ambulances and trucks and so on that we
have there are there is a lot that is
needed we are trying to get you uh uh
those needs and whatever help you can
offer and I really the media people are
to help us here the media people have to
bring the needs to the right people and
make some noise about it so that we
solve it we cannot do it by ourselves
you are our partners
sanctions it's something what I can say
is now these are the things that we have
the situation we need generators we need
to replace and repair water pumps we
need to make sure that there is security
we need to make sure that we can move
quickly and move to to provide the
assistance
whoever is listening please help us to
get moving on this and we'll think later
about the wider question
of the of the sections you have uh
mentioned on the cholera what I know I
think is that we got two million uh
vaccines for uh the
the Northeast and uh and the
government's uh of Syria controlled uh
areas
and I think we are getting and got
already some 1.6 million shots also for
the northwest
this is now and this is before
the uh the earthquake and now because of
the earthquake and because now people
are again crowding in some places and
their sources of water are again being
affected I heard this is happening in
gazian tip and other places it is also
happening in halab and in la de Kia at
least so we will be facing this
Water Sanitation again crisis
and crowded areas so I guess we might
see a Resurgence that we started
controlling thank to your support we
might see a Resurgence again of Cholera
in those places and we need more we need
more for everybody
everybody
thank you
Alan please
thanks so much for doing this briefings
briefing I have a question for both of
you if I may yesterday we've heard that
after the assessment on the ground being
made the U.N May launched the
Urgent appeal human flesh appeal I
wonder if this appeal would be
conducted for both will it be the joint
appeal for turkey and Syria or
separately one for Syria and one for
turkey and the second question if I may
is regarding the Dharma pledge
conference are there any plans is the
U.N planning any donor pledge conference
to hold any donor pledge conference for
Syria thank you
Mustafa you'd like me to start minority
might be a better play
sure uh on the on the on the flash
appeal first of all uh you have to
understand again uh that we are at the
beginning of a crisis so we have our
teams all over trying to gather as much
as information but also to verify that
information right now we have flash
reports which are not covering the whole
country but we're hoping with the next
24 hours our flash reports will cover
the whole of Syria but now it's it's a
bit difficult after that we're moving
into a flash appeal that of course we
were talking about the whole of Syria
the whole of Syria here so Syria is one
country were approaching it but as far
as I know uh the flash appeal for Syria
and turkey are to separate the two
separate countries that's as far as as I
know and I haven't heard anything about
having a joint a joint flash appeal
between uh between both so my colleague
Al Mustafa and myself will be focusing
on the flash appeal for uh for Syria on
the uh on the donor pledging conference
uh what we know is we still have the
senior official
meeting which will be held late March
and then the process conference I think
those are dates that have been discussed
tentatively uh we haven't heard that
those dates will be will be changed nor
that will be any uh special uh
conference for uh to respond to the
crisis of the uh of the earthquake thank
you
yeah I I think that's it we have a flash
appear coming soon and that's for all
Syria
and IT addresses the immediate needs
that the human target needs attached to
this specific specific uh after
earthquake
challenges but I think that because of
this the crisis will get a little bit
deeper and heavier in all of Syria and
we might need to look again in a couple
of months or three months at our
humanitarian response plan and include
the new aspects that are brought up by
this crisis and also
the early recovery that is needed if we
had recovered the capacities that we had
if we had done it properly ahead we
would be in a better better position now
to face what happened a couple of days
ago that's very important and we should
not forget it yesterday I'd want to to
make one clarification of course the
process conference is not a U.N pledging
conference uh it's not a U.N pledging
conference so the U.N is not arranging
any pledging conference it's the member
state so our who are pledging that thank
you thank you
thank you Kristen salumi from Al Jazeera
a couple points of clarification if I
could a couple quick questions on the
cross border you said on the cross line
you said there were nine convoys cross
line in the last seven to eight months
cross-border this is a there are daily
passages is that correct would I be
accurate in saying that convoys go
through there daily normally
and then when you talk about the two who
planes that are trying to get in would
they land directly in the Northwest is
that the issue
that you're negotiating or or would they
have would those planes land in Damascus
and then be delivered is that what is
being worked out do you have any Clarity
on that and then also just so I
understand correctly you are giving the
example of uh one I think it was just
one town where you were talking about
um 20 000 homes that have been impacted
and the rough calculation you were doing
can you just clarify that is what region
that was or what town that was and do
you have any numbers for the
grand scheme of things any for the
entire country thanks
yes yes okay I'll take those if you
don't mind
uh okay for the cross yes definitely the
cross-border it's was the kind of the
normal
way of getting assistance to the
Northwest and we tried after the
security Council decisions and we
brought it to a 10 we had 10 crossline
convoys up to recently before the the
crisis and we are planning these days
for the 11th and 12th
that's the the cross line but when per
month or per day
again
[Music]
I didn't hear you oh I'm sorry you were
that was cross line okay I thought but
for a cross-border I'm sorry go ahead
no I'm talking about crossline then you
there was a question about the two
planes when we are talking about
assisting the people of Syria who are
suffering from this earthquake we're not
talking about Northwest and north south
and Southwest and everything we are
talking about all of them the planes I
mentioned before are the planes that
will come here to Damascus and we will
get the the the support to wherever it
is and that's where we need
I can say that's from this side we're
getting the facilitation but we need all
the actors to first put the People First
and facilitate the access we cannot let
some the situation prevent us from
providing the support where it's needed
the last question it's about the the
twenty thousand uh
20 000 units where people live and
hundred thousands is an estimate that's
only for halib Aleppo
and the the team today yesterday went to
LA decia I think or this afternoon went
to lader here for a
a fast and quick assessment but we have
the undak team that is coming to do a
much more professional and deep
assessment of the needs and they will
visit all the areas and they're here and
I hope we can find a way of wherever
they come from north or south
we need to have access to see the real
magnitude of the of the disaster
and we need your help to really bring
this to the attention of all the people
to facilitate it those with influence
should help us facilitate this
and I I'm I'm quite optimistic I I tend
to be optimistic and hopefully my
optimism will not fail me
that's it will happen
just to follow up then to clarify on the
cross-border those are normally daily
deliveries
pre-earthquake it was daily that
deliveries were coming across the border
they could be daily delivers yes some
days we would have I mean but on average
I I think on certain months we reached
about five six hundred trucks uh it
depends it depends on the month
sometimes they there could be a week
with seven convoys there could be a week
with less more it it depends it depends
on so many things
but the answer is it's much more than
the cross line thank you I just had a
really quick follow-up on Kristen's
question there you you've said a few
times now put the people first
facilitate the access calling on those
with influence to help facilitate the
access what what do you mean by that who
has influence on whom and who is not
allowing access
I can answer that Mustafa if you like
you know
we're here working for the best interest
of the people we don't believe our role
is to start pointing finger at which
party is blocking us our job is to keep
engaging with different authorities to
make sure that we have that all the
required facilities approvals to reach
to reach the people uh the the the
political support we're asking is for
those who have influence on the member
states
on the parties who issue those
facilitation to make our job much more
easier but we're not in a position here
to say this or that because as I said
it's a very complex situation it's a war
zone it's an active war zone and our
main our main objective and interest is
the people and making sure that we we
reach them and staying away from the
politics thank you
so we are taking a few questions online
before taking the last questions here in
the room umid please go ahead of your
question
thank you so much my name is I am from
the Arabic daily I could sell Arabi
and many of my questions I had had been
asked already about especially the
sanctions but my question about the aid
that go into turkey
and the airport at razi and tab is
operational now and many of the flights
carrying humanitarian Aid is landing in
rajienta with that
be split or be divided between both the
affected area in Northern Syria and the
South Eastern Turkey or that is going to
Turkey only
thank you
usually donations and specially flights
they come earmarked so the donors when
they send them they send them for a
specific for the specific country so
there is no split here there are no
percentages the day it is coming for
Northwest Syria it will go there if it's
gone for 30 it will go there but we can
speak on behalf of turkey but I heard
many countries said we're sending aids
to both the Turkish people and the yeah
but they sent it they send it already
knowing which is which Aid is going to
whom I mean it's not us uh we we're not
we don't prioritize needs uh so that's
not our job AIDS when when when cargo
come it comes with a bill of lading uh
airway bill clear uh with a clear
consignee thank you
thank you my name is
newspaper I have a few follow-ups uh so
just to clarify uh what you said about
the aid you are delivering through
babilah do you believe that
um you have that it is enough in the
sense or do you need uh other cross
border uh points to be open to help you
in your operation and then uh to clarify
also something you said about the
crossline and cross-border do you have
uh an idea about the percentage of the
aid you deliver through crossline to
North Syria what percentage is through
cross line and what percentage like is
it 10 of the age you deliver and then my
last question you talked about the needs
uh the basic needs from food and shelter
Etc but there are also other basic needs
like psychological support that people
need specifically the fact that they are
in a war zone uh is there any uh
psychological uh Aid or anyone from your
uh whether the U.N on other organization
who is providing this and trying to
support people there thank you very much
Mustafa can I start on this yeah it
starts on the crossbird thank you yes
thanks everybody Sam I just want to let
you know let me start with your last
question of course in in the case of the
of the crisis usually uh what what
humanitarians look first is that search
and rescue then you have the the medical
the medical support then you have of
course the shelter sanitation food water
and then the psychosocial support and
the protection which is a cross-cutting
issue through through all of them this
is when it comes to the uh to the uh to
the earthquake before that of course we
had all of those supports adding to that
education uh gender-based violence all
the protection issues so those those
systems are in place uh that were
addressing the needs of the four million
people in or you know as needed in in
northwest of of Syria uh on the uh on
the additional uh on the additional
Crossing points you know it goes back to
what both Mustafa and myself were saying
earlier we both look at cross-border
cross line as complementary and if we're
given another another one or two
Crossing points we will definitely take
that at the end of the day we are in the
business of saving lives so we ask for
what we want and we do with what we get
if they give us one crossing point we
will we will do our best to save lives
with that but we would like to have more
flexibility uh to do more on the
breakdown between cross-border and
crossline of course most of the Aid
comes through cross-border not through
crossline and that's why and Mustafa is
and of course myself are both trying to
increase the cross line
to a level uh where we can reach more
people we hope we can get to a state a
cross line and cross-border can be
decided on efficiency and Effectiveness
thank you
would like to add anything
and also we have one more question
online uh Yvonne can I can I follow up
very quickly
um they were there were also some
reports and I don't know if you can
confirm that about the possibility that
through the earthquake and the cows that
comes with it that maybe some families
and children are separated from their
families to which extent you try to
follow up on that and try to make sure
that these children are safe and
thank you
because this is a priority the
protection issues are priorities the
women and the children our priorities
the the humanitarian agencies they all
work you know right now they're you know
they're busy as I said with the search
and rescue but there are other
specialized agencies ngos including the
Syria ngos who are looking into this
it's difficult it's hard it's
challenging it's a it's a life-saving
situation there as as you can see people
are fighting with time to save lives of
people so I can assure you that
everybody uh eptisam is trying his best
thank you thank you Yvonne please
may I add something to this one uh as uh
I was talking to colleagues who are
right there on the in the hubs in halap
and other classes and they mentioned
this point where we have to be careful I
mean those areas where the people are
crowded we are also looking at the
issues of protection
the area that's our normal work if there
are children who are separated from
families we are also working on that we
are trying to avoid to to prevent all
those things from happening the
psychological support it's a dramatic a
traumatic uh kids and also support is
part of our work our people are working
already on this particularly in the
cases where kids
are still and there are a lot of stress
from what's Happening before the the
earthquake and now add to it the
earthquake yes we are looking at that
and uh well XL and XB we're not talking
about now numbers yes we were very small
but now we're talking about how can we
help those who how can we get access to
those who need help
full stop we've talked about figures
later I just have to say that I have a
hard stop exactly in in two minutes I
don't know about al-mustafa but I in two
minutes I have to leave so over to you
thank you so Yvonne please yes thank you
um thank you very much for this briefing
Yvonne Murray from RTE it's actually
just a point of clarification did I
understand correctly that there are
Supply trucks waiting at the border full
of supplies that can't yet get across
and did you say that those supplies will
deplete fairly soon
what we said is we have trucks ready
ready to cross we've we haven't the
logistics operation of preparing for the
convoys they didn't stop we have a
transshipment uh at the transshipment
Hub uh the loading uh is is ongoing so
we're just waiting for our threats to be
able to make it to the final point to
the to the border and cross but there
are trucks that have to come from the
other side it's a back-to-back Logistics
complex operation that's what we're
saying we just need both trucks to
arrive how long have you got before
those supplies deplete
uh but that uh we I'm not sure how much
stocks we have but I can tell you that
those are non-food items uh I'm not sure
what exactly the trucks are loaded with
but I to the best of my recollection and
I'll have to verify this I think that
non-food items that are waiting there I
know that the world food program have
before the uh before the the earthquake
pre-positioned uh food there so we we
they have some food supplies the ones
that we're hoping to cross with are
non-food architects
that's that's actually the case and it
applies to the the world food program
also with all pre-positioned
supplies and that's where I was
mentioning it's enough supplies for 100
000 people for one week
so I don't know whether that number
includes the supplies that are on the
side of the crossword of gaussianship
but I think that's the supplies from
this from Samantha sagmada
thank you very much I believe that Mr
has to leave he run out of time
thank you so much for joining us today
perhaps Mr Miller could get one more
question from the room and I think that
we finished after that
thank you so much for this uh briefing
and for your time Chris Reyes with the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation
summary question uh if we can just zero
in on on your most immediate challenges
for the next few days of the mission
which I imagine there are is a very
critical time period can you define one
or two big specific hurdles that's
hampering you from taking action right
now and and what's the specific ask from
the International Community just for the
next few days
for the next few days
we are still struggling with the search
and rescue equipment
we are will need more in terms of food
and medical and we are getting some now
through who but we will definitely need
more
we need more people to support the teams
that are working in there
and in fact we uh what I'm talking about
here includes also some of the support
that is coming from the international
ngos and National ngos we work with them
very closely they also need support they
need help
we need the the for the cold
the winter necessities
that is needed
desired one the hurdles we have
if I talk about the uh the area under
government control we don't have an
access problem in terms of
authorizations but we have an access
problem in terms of the capacity of the
infrastructure to authorize to enable us
to do it I mean this means we might have
to repair a few roads here and there and
we are not the only one government is
also working on that but we are in a in
a situation where it has
it was already difficult to do that
before
and now we are in a suggestion where we
don't have any other option than doing
it
and the second one is the fuel
we luckily we had some stock that was
prepared because we are suffering with
this so we put we had formed some stock
of fuel that this time it will again
vanish very quickly be depleted very
quickly we will need all the support to
import it let me add something I had the
meeting we had an HCT meeting this
morning and the representatives of a
national ngos were there and the
international ngos were there and all of
them said that they need help and
support and funding please help them
support them and fund them the second
point is the national NGO said the
people of Syria who need help just lost
the opportunity of getting that help
because we had promises and people are
calling us the diaspora and other people
to say we want to help you how do we get
the money for you they cannot get the
money
transferred here in Syria
die cuts
I think you understand why
thank you very much I don't think we
have any further questions uh Mr
billamily thank you so much for your
precious uh time and best wishes with
your critical work thank you very much
thank you thanks for inviting me thank
you have a great day all your questions
and rely on you
thank you very much have a great day
everyone thanks